A Kubernetes cluster has two sides.
The control plane that thinks, and the nodes that do.
The control plane manages.
Worker nodes run your workloads.
Five components.
First, KubeAPER server.
The front door.
All API traffic goes here.
It scales horizontally.
Second, ECT.
The database.
All cluster state lives here.
Back it up.
Third, Kube scheduler.
Watches for new pods with no assigned node.
Picks the right one based on resources, constraints, affinity, deadlines.
Fourth, Kube controller manager.
Runs controller processes, node, job, and point slice service account compiled into
one binary.
Watches for drift.
Fixes it.
Fifth, Cloud controller manager.
Cloud integrations only.
Not present on-prem or local clusters.
On every node, three things.
KubeLit, the agent, ensures containers in a pod are running and healthy.
Kube Proxy, optional, implements service networking, can be replaced by network plugins.
Container runtime, containered, or CRIO, actually runs your containers.
Every cluster runs these pieces.
Now you know what they do.
Run the docs, Kubernetes cluster components.